we are
there onesies with my beans dear friend
Tony Collette and what the clip you just
saw was her latest film Mafia mama and
we're in our Wednesdays recreating
a moment already I don't even remember
what that was what was it in the movie
or were we just hanging out I think it
was yeah I don't even I don't remember
but that was us and so we're literally
in the Uggs and the onesies just back in
our happy place
and in honor of the movie we have this
gorgeous Italian spread thank you so
much now
um Tony I can't believe you're cooking I
mean well I someone was like do the
asparagus on the grill and I was like I
haven't done it yet so I'm just taking
this time to learn I'm trying to learn
how to make this dish while I talk to
you
well that was terrible
oh shoot that was even worse all right
there we go no it's perfect look I'm
rough I can eat shell I don't care all
right good for you do not understand
why
okay I
how do I phrase this I don't know will
you please do more comedies you are the
most amazing comedian I
I
what did you
I know you I know your body of work I
there is a Lucille Ball level of Comedy
going on with you in this movie it is so
next level funny it is properly wet your
pants funny like it is properly wet your
pants funny it is like Under the Tuscan
Sun meets The Godfather it is this
delightful romp it is an empowerment
story there's an arc and an evolution
but you what did you Channel who are you
going for what were you tapping into
because there's a comedy style here that
is very hard to pull off I what I mean
literally I was just going with the
script whatever I felt when I read it
and it came to me through covert which
was such a challenging time for so many
people and it was just like this Beacon
of pulping light and I was like we're
gonna get this out in the world this is
a beautiful baby that everyone needs to
hold and this it's a comedy but there's
action and it's quite violent and some
of it is that's why it's like The
Godfather
we had to keep it grounded we had to
keep it a real threat my character needs
to be like a total Fish Out of Water
totally overwhelmed like unaware of how
everything's going down and it's and
it's dangerous so and you've got she
goes to Italy to go to her grandfather's
funeral only to find out that she is a
part of this family
but it's like the Mayhem ensues there
are scenes and set pieces where the
entire thing is writing on your
performance and it's in a beautiful
setting and there are great people with
you and everybody in the film is so good
everyone is very good yeah but it's like
this is a film about a woman's
performance that's one of the strongest
comedic performances I've seen in so
long
[Applause]
so nice to me thank you you know you you
go and you make these all right I'm
gonna just shove it on that's already
cooked I'm a rebel Homemaker apparently
um this is what I do I mess up in the
kitchen there we go this is my version
this is delicious all right I did it
okay here
it's not horrible this is good it's
edible
um okay
um this also did you decide that you
know that something like this
delightful beautiful oh I was actually
making this for you that's for me yeah
baby okay I'll give you this
um yeah exactly um thank you honey
welcome okay so what are you like up to
in life right now what's what's going on
in life uh I've been away from home
doing prayers for like five weeks I'm
gonna get home to my baby so I just miss
it's so funny when I'm shooting
something thing because the focus is so
great it's not that I don't miss them
but I just have this greater focus and
doing press is a very different thing so
I'm like my body hurts like my heart is
like where are they and I you know I've
become a real I was into it before but I
meditate a lot that's been completely
life-changing what do you do like 20
minutes a day I have no rule I just sit
and I I get into a state of bliss I've
been doing it for a long time I used to
like really merge and it felt like a
death it was like I don't exist anymore
it scared me so I stopped but as I've
gotten older I've started doing it again
it's super relaxing and very centering
and it makes every day so much better I
love it really yeah yeah yeah what else
in life what are you up to what are you
doing what do you mean I don't know
what's fun right now
um what's fun right now I I am Rome was
life-changing I just love it there I
feel like I I want one foot in Australia
and one foot in Italy It's The Most
Beautiful Place could you ever do both I
mean we talked to a family today who got
on a bus and and it goes around around
America for a year and does whatever
they want and but they have a mission
for goodness
um but it's amazing I know yeah look
don't you think you get to the point
you're like all these societal rules why
do we adhere to them I'm just going to
live how I want so yes maybe I will just
do that okay so if you could do anything
right now for like the next year and it
would be completely conducive to your
life and the rules don't apply you would
do half the year in Australia half the
year in Italy I would be a grab at my
kids and swim as much as possible follow
the Sun follow the joy that's it I do I
think I I've been working since I was so
young that I think I'm conditioned you
know we're all conditioned we're all
conditioned yeah you go to decondition I
would I'd like to decondition I like to
decondition with you all right Tony
Collette Mafia mama is in theaters today
and check out Tony in a new episode of
the power exclusively on Prime video and
we'll be right back to recreate that
onesie photo
thank you